[Music]
Two spells are applied to both conditions, and
no one will be injured.
As a general rule, students can only meet
in this condition. There is
no limit to the selling time. It can be fatal to the head or chest, but it can be fatal
to either side.  If that's the case, that's it. Then, with
both of them in position, Oliver
asks for his help. Nanao is an
amateur when it comes to magic, so let's
seal
away the magic and end it at a reasonable point.
[Music] I'm
not someone you can go easy on.
[Music] I
can't take it.
Grave Tori.
[Music] Let your
power flow
[Music] It's
here
[Music]
This is no joke. I've been killing people. It's
probably not 20 days and nights.
How much blood has been spilled?
[Music] It's all over
here
[Music]
Don't cry.  I want to stop those tears, I'll do whatever I can to stop those tears, I'll do everything I
can to be who I am now
[Music] I can't stay like
this until one of us takes our last breath Both of us can
draw our swords I never should have said this, I'll
seriously cut you off  I may not have been conscious of saying that, but
what was I trying to do now when I nullified the non-killing spell?